to very warmly welcome the
President of the European Commission
Ursula Vender LAN
[Applause]
[Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you
very much thank you very much and hello to my
friends of
renaissance dear Stéphane stayed
ladies and gentlemen ministers
ladies  and gentlemen
parliamentarians, dear members of the
Renaissance party, dear
friends, I am delighted to be here among you
to inaugurate this plenary session of
your European campus, but allow me
before entering into the subject which
brings us together today to discuss the
very serious situation in the Middle East I
condemn with the greatest firmness
the senseless attack carried out by Hamas
against
Israel
this violence is neither a
political solution nor an act of bravery it is
purely terrorism and Israel has the
right to
defend itself the European Union stands
alongside Israel and dear friends this
ordeal is added to the long list of challenges
that we are overcoming
together first of all I would like to
thank renew Europe and in particular
Stéphane
stayed for everything  the work that we
have done
together and my dear friends this assessment is
also
yours this invitation does me great
honor especially since it is quite
rare for a political party to decide to
focus its summer school on
Europe  and this proof once again
your Renaissance party has Europe at
heart this unites you and me proof
also of your
conviction that the future of France
its
prosperity and its capacity to control
its destiny are strongly linked to
Europe  that's what you call in
French, I believe, a community of
destiny, an expression that I
really like because it emphasizes what
really matters. European countries form a
community, I would even say a family,
through geography,
yes, but  also and above all by the
values ​​and the often
painful lessons of the
past and it is the strength of this
community which allows us to face
our common destiny because it is indeed a question
of
destiny the word is not too strong in
the  troubled times that we are experiencing our
common destiny during the
covid-19 crisis our common destiny facing the
consequences of
global warming our common destiny facing
Russia's brutal challenge to
the security of our
continent our common destiny finally facing
the profound  technological mutations
mutations often bringing
progress but which redraw the
global map of competitiveness and
prosperity which goes
with none of these challenges stops at the
borders drawn on the maps and
those who say the opposite and then
call France  to close in on
itself and
make it
weaker on the
contrary it is the opposite France
will be more prosperous by continuing what
has made its success and corresponds to
its best
heritage by being
proactive by fully engaging
with  by European partner by
taking its full place at the heart of the
European project as it has done in
recent
years your representatives in the
European Parliament and the Council of Ministers your
local elected officials your companies and
civil society actors who lead so many
European projects  know this
Europe well, it is they who create it and
give it shape, it is your Europe, you are
Europe, those who block and only
denigrate weaken our Europe
in a world of 8 billion inhabitants
where  The entire European Union
weighs only 500 million, unity is
strength, everyone for themselves is ineffective
and
illusory, the future of France and
our European Union depends on each
other, that's our community.  of
destiny and ladies and gentlemen my
dear friends
I said that we have Europe at
heart our action at European level we
are the best
witness in the face of each crisis for 4 years
our European Union has made enormous
leaps
forward think of our  common health response
to the
covid crisis Romanian doctors treating
patients in Italian hospitals
German patients treated in
French hospitals and
French patients treated in
German hospitals and here is
European solidarity in
action we then
guaranteed that hundreds of  million
Europeans are receiving vaccines and these
vaccines have arrived in all
Member States with no difference between large and
small North and South East or West they
were largely manufactured in
Europe and we have launched next
generation EU and at 800  billion euros
and its French component France relaunched
very many businesses
were saved from bankruptcy and jobs were
protected France and Europe
continued to grow unemployment
continued to fall and we
invested massively to  prepare for
the future and thanks to our
common action it is a stronger, more
agile, more united Europe that has emerged from this
crisis and we owe all this to
our common work, it is our
collective success and I find that we
we can be very proud of it my
dear
friends
in this transformation your support is
not limited to our responses to
crises we work together to
carry out the major projects that
I defined at the start of the
mandate and
firstly dear Pascal confin the green PACT
European the European Green PACT our
new sustainable growth strategy
we have adopted the Law on
climate neutrality in
2050 and all the
sectoral legislative proposals to
achieve this such as the carbon tax at
borders for example it will ensure
equality between our companies and those
of the rest  of the world and will provide
predictability and direction for our
entrepreneurs and investors we
are
determined to fight
global warming thanks to the
European Green Deal
then the
digital decade our DSA and DMA legislation
regulates the digital world and allows
European companies to compete
with
foreign competitors  we have encouraged the
production of semiconductors manufactured
in Europe and the development of
clean technologies these proposals strengthen
our technological sovereignty and
attract investments to Europe
see the battery factories emerging
in France in Sweden and elsewhere in Europe
these are concrete examples
another subject on which we demonstrate
voluntarism a major issue in the eyes of
our citizens is
migration we are moving forward on the adoption
of the aspects of our migration and
asylum pact this is the central element of the
long-term solution  but migrants
are arriving every day at the moment and
this is leading to dramatic situations
like in Lampedusa where I
recently went my dear friends I want
to be very
clear Europe respects and will respect
its obligations as a member of the
international community because this  corresponds to our
humanist values
but it is we Europeans who will decide
who can come to the European Union
and in what circumstances it
will be neither smugglers nor
human traffickers Europe
manages migration in a way that is both
effective  and
human
and as you can see, the projects are
numerous and all this we do
together but your support,
allow me to
emphasize it, is not unconditional, it
is demanding and ambitious and that is
very good
because you carry a
message a strategic vision which
resonates more and more in
Europe you have the strong desire
to be able to influence
world events it is the vision
of a France and a more
sovereign and powerful Europe in an
unstable world which deals with  'equal with
their partners and
competitors whether in the
industrial or
commercial field or on the issues of
digital food
space or
military sovereignty the President of the Republic
structured this ambition in his
Sbonne speech at the start of his
first mandate  how far we have come
since my dear
friends
the French presidency of the
Council at the very beginning of the
Russian invasion of Ukraine demonstrated the
relevance of this approach and the
Versailles summit
concretized the broad
European convergence on these subjects the facts
since  have proven us
right the most striking example is for
sure that of our
past energy dependence on
Russia during the Versaill summit
only 18
months ago we gave ourselves the objective
of drastically reducing our
dependence on Russian gas and  we did it
we reduced our imports
of Russian gas by pipeline from 50% before
the invasion to less than 10%
now the Russian war in Ukraine
also shows us
the importance of maintaining control of
advanced technologies and  to develop
significantly develop our
defense capabilities that's what we
do staying open to the world by being
realistic and clear about our values ​​and
priorities that's what we
do we develop
strategic partners in the areas of
critical raw materials through  example
with Chile we invest in
future technologies crucial for
our
independence such as low
carbon hydrogen, solar and wind power
finally we have learned to
defend ourselves we impose
reciprocity in public markets
we
control we control
foreign investments  in our
strategic companies we are fighting
against dumping we have not forgotten
how
China's unfair commercial practices have affected our
solar panel industry but
we have learned lessons from it the
European Commission has therefore decided to
launch an
anti-subsidy investigation into
electric vehicles coming from
China in short a France and a Europe
listen and respect in the world this is the
whole meaning of our action Ladies and
Gentlemen dear
friends we do all this not
only for economic
and
security reasons but above all for our values
for our European model of
society a model of which we are proud
and which we value above all
our
individual freedom the rule of law which
protects us the
permanent search for a more just
inclusive society which makes room for everyone
whatever  their gender the color of their
skin or their
beliefs
and I believe deeply in the motto of
your
Republic
freedom
equality
fraternity
and I believe and I also believe
deeply in that of our
European Union united in
diversity
we must bring its values ​​to life both at
inside and outside our
borders inside we have
continued to promote the place of
women in our
society it is a fight that is close to my
heart that is close to our hearts and we
can be proud that after  years
of blockage our legislation on the
place of women on boards
of directors has been
adopted
we can be proud to have
achieved equal pay
between men and women there is no
reason to pay a woman less for  the
same work as a
man
of common sense you explain to me but what a
fight we also recently
proposed a European law on
violence against women and
domestic violence we must never
hit a woman we must never
mutilate a girl and  my dear friends
no means
no
[Music]
and my dear friends I am counting on you and
your support to have this
law adopted which will guarantee
this, even
Europe stands up against
discrimination it is written in black and
white in our European charter of
human rights we will
never accept that European funds go
to countries that do not respect the
principles of this
charter we use all our
legal instruments to block
European funds to countries or regions
that discriminate against LG LGBTQI
or any other minority because Europe
is equality and Europe is
diversity and that is also why
we are fighting for respect for the rule of
law and in particular for
judicial independence the lack  of
judicial independence that is the very foundations of our
democracies it is a long and
difficult fight but it is an
essential fight dear
friends I said that we must bring
these values ​​to life both inside
and outside our
borders and I want to discuss with you
my convictions on the situation in
Armenia and in the region of
Nagorno-Karabach I was able to reiterate to
Armenian Prime Minister Pasinian all
my support for Armenia during our
meeting in
Granada I
condemn I very much condemn  firmly
the military operation of Azerbaijan
which led to the exodus of more than 100,000
Armenians from the
Nagorno-Karabakh region and I reaffirm my
absolute support for the
territorial integrity of Armenia in accordance with
the principles of the United Nations
in  our immediate priority is
to help Armenia welcome
displaced people and to support the
Armenian state in this ordeal. We will
double our immediate humanitarian aid
and we will provide
budgetary support to Armenia. In addition, we will
organize with  the
United States a joint meeting in
support of Armenia
this is a first step in
strengthening our
bilateral relations because Europe and Armenia
share a long and rich
common history and the time has come to write
a  new chapter in this
common story ladies and gentlemen amiszo
ended with the most vital of our
current fights the fight against the
Russian invasion of
Ukraine Putin's Russia massacres
innocent people by the thousands deports
women and children and tries to mock
the map a
sovereign country a permanent member of the
UN Security Council attacks a
peaceful neighbor we will never accept it we
will never accept the law of the
strongest we will always defend the Charter
of the United Nations and
international law our response  European to
the Russian invasion of Ukraine has been
exemplary 4 million refugees
Ukraine welcomed 92 billion in aid
for Ukraine early and
massive sanctions coordinated with our
partners which weaken the
Russian capacity to wage this war and a large
majority
of Europeans understanding and supporting
our action, that's a source of great pride,
thank you very much for that
and I know I know that I can count
on you because France has met
its responsibilities and
will continue to do so, we will support
Ukraine as long as it is necessary
because defending Ukraine is defending
our Europe trying to defend the values
of France
slavaukra
Ladies and Gentlemen dear
friends the opening of France to Europe
and the
world Bordeaux is  a
perfect illustration ah here are the students of
Bordeaux a not known throughout the
world a splendid city anchored in
history and with an exceptional heritage
but which has known how to adapt and renew itself
I would even say who has known and I am thinking of
Michel Montaigne  a real
renaissance a city so French and
yet so international this
perfectly sums up our European project I
wish you excellent debates on
this project I am counting on your
enthusiasm and your creativity to
move our Europe forward long live
Europe
thank you
ladies and gentlemen